hey y'all hope you're doing well welcome
back to my channel where we talk about
tech and life and other things also
today is one of those other things also
where we talk about what's on my iPhone
this is a very popular video that I've
seen with a lot of lifestyle youtubers
so I thought that I would show you what
is on my phone and also how I use my
phone I was an iOS engineer for five or
six years and so I don't know if that
necessarily gives me a leg up and
thinking about how apps work and how our
consume apps but that's for you to
decide I'm just here to show you today
how I use this thing so yeah I see my
phone as a tool I know that in a lot of
ways I owe a lot to the iPhone because
without it I probably would be in a very
different job I wouldn't have been
making apps for this thing for five or
six years but I use it as a tool for
social time at our tainment time I use
it for staying connected enough to date
with work and I also use it as a tool
for productivity and wellness and self
like improvement I guess there's a lot
of things that this little thing does
and I am always grateful for so today
I'm going to show you what's inside so
the phone itself is an iPhone 10 running
the latest version of iOS which is 13
not 3.1 I think this one is 256 gigs and
I've got this cool yeah
birds-of-paradise case right now I just
found it at Best Buy and I needed
something that protected the edges and
my old one was dying so I bought this
one and it's been working great and my
homescreen picture my lockscreen picture
and my homescreen picture is this
picture that I drew of Kona a couple
months ago that's kind of the lay of the
land I don't think I'm gonna go through
every single app because I think some of
them are self-explanatory but I will go
through kind of at least row by row in
it at least a couple of sentences of
each so I'm gonna start with a very
bottom row because this is like the most
important row of apps on my phone which
has the calling phone phone app what
what is this what
this can cause phone phone let's just
call it the phone app and then I have
messages Spotify and camera those four
are the ones that I use the most often
and are most convenient for me to reach
towards at the very bottom and it should
just stay there so those are like my top
four you know remember like these are my
space he had top eight but these are my
top four apps and then I guess I'll just
work backwards from the bottom up so in
the very bottom row the first app is an
app called Kadesh you this is kind of
like BuzzFeed tasty but for Japanese
food and Japanese food recipes so
they've got a bunch of like quick video
tutorials on how to make different
Japanese foods which has been really
good for me to expand my repertoire of
different Japanese foods that I can make
I don't have Japanese television at home
so this has been a good way to just like
explore what are all the things that I
can make it has like obviously just
Japanese food but these all they've also
got desserts and other kinds of things
like that
and it's just really easy to watch you
know those like really cute quick recipe
videos so that's Kadesh you I also have
the New York Times cooking app I am a
New York Times Online subscriber and the
cooking app is awesome there are so many
good recipes on here and they have
published so many recipes over the years
and so I also just like perusing this to
see what is on and what could I make it
really does expand my world and I like
that I don't have to buy a bunch of
cookbooks to be able to see all these
this is actually where I found like my
recipe for the cardamom bread that I
like to make as well as the Japanese
milk bread and these I have on my home
screen because I eat every day and I
like perusing them to just at least get
some inspiration for what I'm gonna eat
after that I've got focus keeper which
is a Pomodoro timer if you're not
familiar with Pomodoro it's a technique
to help you focus and it usually has the
format of focusing for 25 minutes
one task and then a five-minute break
and then that repeats over and over
again as long as you need but this is a
good timer to help me track those 25
minutes you can turn on sounds you can
turn off sounds I just think it looks
really pretty and its aesthetic and I
like the red color so it's just a good
app to do that the next app that I want
to talk about is blink is who is
actually the sponsor of this video I
found out about bling cast a couple
years ago from friends and it's
basically a way to easily consume just
summarized versions of books that maybe
you've always wanted to read you can
read them in text format you can also
listen to some of them in audio format
and it's been so good I actually really
like using this app and I'm really happy
that they're sponsoring today it's been
a really good way to read books that are
nonfiction personally I don't really get
through a lot of nonfiction books on my
own because they tend to be very lengthy
and really what I'm looking for are just
a couple of points that are the kind of
the main themes of the book and
blingiest condenses this information
into text or audio that you can consume
within 15 minutes so I actually used to
use this on my commutes I would listen
to an entire book on my commute and that
would be awesome because then I can
really just figure out what are the
points of the book and then I can go
about my day without needing to spend
hours and hours and hours reading a book
because I don't have time for that and I
also do have the patience for that to be
honest now it seems like there are just
so many books that we are recommended
especially when we're in the tech
industry and I have a ever-growing list
of books and so I like reading them on
blinkin this is the list of big books
that I have been listening to through
blankest
especially things like Thinking Fast and
Slow the people vs. tech these are all
titles that I had heard of before but I
don't want to spend hours and hours and
hours reading them two of the books that
I really enjoyed listening to on
blankets are the creative curve curve
there we go by Allen Gannett this talks
about the science behind creativity and
I also read the subtle art
not giving up I marked Manson this book
has been on shelves for so long and I've
always seen it with its bright orange
color and I've always wondered what it
was about so I just listened to it I'm
Linkous which was super easy and super
quick and so I really recommend those
two books along with so many other
titles on blankest because blinkin is
the sponsor of this video the first 100
people to sign up with a link below
blink is calm slash Holloway you go are
going to get a limited access for an
entire week completely for free as well
as 25% off if you want the full
membership so yeah thank you so much a
blink is for sponsoring and thank you
also for making a good app that I
actually really enjoyed using the row
above that I have some various messaging
apps I've got discord to help me talk to
people on my discord server which is
always fine I also have whatsapp and I
don't use whatsapp myself very often but
a lot of my friends do and so I have it
downloaded for them like my two high
school friends love using whatsapp so
that's what we're on line is also on my
home screen because this is the way that
I can stay connected to my friends and
family in Japan
mostly it's like my grandma and my other
grandma and grandpa as well as my aunt
uncle cousins like before I would just
see them once a year I would call them
every once in a while but line makes it
easy to stay connected that way and I've
never lived near family so this is a
very close second I guess is it arrow
it's just nice to stay connected to them
you know after that I have the Settings
app now one of the things that I wanted
to highlight about the Settings app is
screen time this is one of my favorite
new features on iOS of being able to
track how much you're using your phone
and I use this to just monitor my usage
as well as set app limits
I set app limits for mostly social media
stuff just Facebook and Twitter Twitter
if I'm on it for longer than five
minutes then I usually just go into a
deep pit of how because everything is
I don't really want to stay there for
that long so I said a limit on myself
and Facebook I don't really need to be
on Facebook for more than 15 minutes a
day so I said that I like being able to
monitor this because if I see that my
usage goes over four or five hours
it usually means that I'm using my phone
too much I find that I generally get
unhappier if I get to that level of
phone consumption so just being able to
monitor my usage every once in a while
has been very good the other thing I
guess settings related that I do on my
phone is that I basically have my phone
always on low battery mode I think he
just prevents like background fetches
and just tries to reduce how apps are
using your battery in the background and
it lengthens the amount that your
battery lasts for so I do that because I
usually drain my battery every single
day next I've got YouTube Netflix
headspace in Amazon YouTube and Netflix
I watch so much stuff all the time on my
phone especially right before bed so
those are in spots on my homescreen
headspace I love I have been wanting to
use headspace regularly for a couple of
years now but it didn't really stick
until maybe December of last year and
I've been using it for daily meditations
I also use it for sleep meditations as
well as just like SOS meditations I
always use their fear of flying
meditation right before I go on a flight
right now I'm using the letting go
stress pack and it's just been really
good for me to stay connected with my
body and just find a sense of calm and
peace and the meditations are not that
long but headspace is one of those apps
that truly bring value to my life and so
that deserves a spot on my home screen
as well I also have Amazon on there
because we buy a lot of things on Amazon
and it's just convenient to be able to
have on my home screen because I often
will think about oh hey I need more
rubber bands or I need like soap or
something and just being able to buy it
right there on my home screen is
and then we got kind of like a social
media ro above that I've got Instagram I
don't really think I need to go into
Instagram you all know what it is I use
vsco to edit my photos to put on my
Instagram I don't use the feed itself
but I just like all of the filters on it
and I pay for the premium subscription
for that it helps me to just correct
photos like color Corrections and being
able to straighten it out as well as
filters so that's on my home screen I'm
one of the Millennials that actually use
Facebook because this is the way that I
stay connected to people that I actually
know all their social media outlets
don't really do that for me right now
and so having somewhere that I can just
stay connected with my friends and my
family I look at it yeah like 15 minutes
a day like I said before on screen time
and yeah I didn't go I'll probably keep
using unless a better alternative shows
up and I also use facebook Messenger
basic Messenger I use way more often
than Facebook specifically because my
immediate family we communicate using
facebook Messenger but in an age where
you also don't exchange phone numbers
and call people anymore Facebook
Messenger has been just really
convenient to talk to people one-on-one
now the two rows above that are kind of
just like my utility ones that I use
every day all the time that have to be
on every phone that I use Safari is my
browser of choice because it's the
native iOS browser I like using that one
more than Chrome or anything else at
least on my phone I also use spark and
calendars as my email and calendar app I
find that it does a little bit more than
the native apps and I like how clean it
is and how easy it is to use so been
using that for a little over a year now
and notes
it's just simple I know there's so many
other note-taking apps out there but
I just dumped everything like this is
just lots of different thoughts that
I've had and they just get put into the
Notes app I got my clock I got my
weather I got my photos and I got my
maps of wish I use Apple Maps because it
connects to carplay very well and it's
not creepy like Google and doesn't like
use my data in a weird way so that is
the very first page of my phone now the
second pages are just kind of like
secondary apps that I use lesson but
still pretty frequently
I have slack on here when I was working
at company slack was usually the main
team communication tool of choice and so
I usually put that on the second page
anyways just because I like being able
to like plug away from work and not need
to look at slack all the time so slack
is on there these days I use it to
communicate with different circles or
friends in groups
I've got YouTube studio on here because
I want to check how things are going and
this is how I reply to comments and Hart
comments and just see how my videos are
doing I have the Wikipedia app also I
downloaded this on a whim but there's so
much that you can learn from having the
Wikipedia app and I do think that it is
easier to read things if you have the
Wikipedia app I have costar which is
like an astrology app which I'm not
going to say that I super believed in
astrology but it does sometimes like it
gives me words for feelings that I'm
feeling or things that I'm thinking
about that I didn't have words for
before and sometimes it feels very on
point other times I'm just like what are
you saying but it's just kind of a fun
thing that I like to check every once in
a while
underneath that I've got app store to
download new apps I've got music this is
where all my old music from itunes what
I used to use iTunes is on there
I have webtoon where I read all of these
comics that I like on every time my
soundTouch app is my
apt to control my Bose speakers and I
can connect it with different radio as
well so that's just been a very useful
thing to have on my phone I use --lift
as often as I can over a goober I have
Yelp to check restaurants Looby is an
app that helps me check out library
books from my local library for free I
have a library card and they can manage
loans and stuff and so I check out books
that way for books that you know I don't
mind taking that long to read or just
like books that are fiction or something
and then I can read them on my Kindle
I've also got this our groceries app
which like it's a very basic groceries
app which has been useful because I can
add to it for things that I need to buy
at different places but I feel like
there's like a better app out there so
if you all know a better app let me know
I also I'm considering just making one
we'll see underneath that more social
media stuff I've got reddit I've got
Twitter which you can see is blocked out
because I've been on Twitter for longer
than five minutes
today I have tic toc which I don't make
any tic toc things but darn is it
addicting and then I have this app
called plant snap I downloaded this on a
whim because I wanted to be able to
identify different plants out in the
wild and it's pretty accurate I would
say it's pretty accurate and it has
helped me learn a lot more plants out
there so call me a plan to near or
horticulturalist is that what it is
under that I have a metronome because I
was playing some violin for the first
time in five years and I was doing some
scales and then I have a folder that
says youtubing this is just all these
tools that I use for for creating videos
so I have like my accounting app I have
and act to help connect to my canon
camera so that I can upload things onto
my phone easily got patreon got pure
space to check out rooms various
note-taking apps Google Drive and asana
which is a project planning app I also
have a folder called real estate because
gotten are looking at real estate right
now and it just keeps it all in that
place so that's my second page is just
kind of like secondary apps that are not
as important but I still want to have a
place for them and not need to go
looking for them third page is just
folders on folders on folders it's just
folders these are apps that I really
don't use that often and frankly I
forget where they all are so oftentimes
I will just open kind of the Siri search
thing and just type it in and then be
able to look at it these are just apps
that I prefer to have on my phone than
not but I don't need them all the time
and I don't even know what need to know
where they are so I've got various
categories I've got delivery for door -
it reads post mates
instacart I've got some entertainment
things Goodreads for books to get
masters for concert tickets
KDF see which is the local classical
radio station in the Bay Area prime
video dave & buster's from when i went
once disney plus I've got Nick over
tickets Danny over video a accessory
ticket so lots of random stuff shopping
I have read up Target IKEA ASOS IKEA
Uniqlo etc I find that like especially
for shopping apps using the native app
tends to be better than using the
website because the website is not
always super mobile friendly and there's
ads and tracking everywhere so I tend to
try to use the app as much as possible
so long as they have one after that I've
got health apps which I'm not really
gonna get into I've got some news apps
I've got some social apps I've got audio
travel some like Internet of Things some
more camera things last I would see
learning Japan app store when I go to
Japan and I needed to learn how to use
the rail system for how to get
everywhere I have a folder of all of the
apps that I don't use a cane stock with
Apple but I can't don't have the heart
to delete that I've got a bunch of games
I only ever play when I'm on an airplane
and I
internets I have a section for manga
that I like to read I have a folder for
mental health apps that I use and then I
have a non parental team which is like
basically banking and insurance stuff
real exciting so that's kind of a tour
of what's on my iPhone
this changes all the time I think i
reorganize and I don't have service so
it's been a couple of weeks since I
reordered this last and it's been
working for me but depending on my life
stage it'll look different but it
usually follows the format of having one
page full of apps and then a secondary
page which may have some apps and then a
bunch of folders I do tend to use Siri
pretty often whenever I can
I've been trying to make more shortcuts
so that my life is a little bit more
simplified this is this is my iPhone I'm
not sure if this is any more interesting
than some randos phone but it is
sometimes interesting to look at iPhone
apps and think about how they're made
and it does give me appreciation for
some apps that are made really
beautifully and done really well so
thank you so much for watching my what's
on my iPhone video and thank you to
wingus again for sponsoring make sure
that you are one of the first 100 people
to get that one week free unlimited
access to the app by clicking in the
link on the description down below we're
going to blink is comm slash hello may
you go make sure to LIKE this video if
you haven't done so already and let me
know in the comments down below what
apps that you enjoy using or that you
can't live without especially if it's
enough that I don't know about I love
learning about new apps and there are so
many apps out there and that is the
beauty of the App Store make sure to
smash the subscribe button and I will
see you next time hope you have a great
day wherever you are
bye
[Music]